the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we have two strings s1 s2 first we're
going to check if the length of s 1 is
equal to length 2 anyone really really
quickly can you tell me what is this the
length of s1 and s2 how many characters
are in there 10 right because we're
including spaces so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
so they are equal first of all so we're
going to go inside this if statement
then we're going to go for every
character in s1 and we're going to have
a nested loop for every character in s2
we're going to check if the two
characters are the same and if they are
we're going to print this common letter
statement and then we're going to break
okay great we have we have some good
competition here so let's see the outer
for loop is first going to go through
the letter M okay
so this is so first it's going to look
at em right for char in s1 the first
character anise one is an M then we're
entering inside this other for loop for
char two in s2 so we're going to say for
this M I'm going to look at I which is
the first character in s2 if the
character 1 is equal to character two
they're not don't do anything keep going
to the next character in us - okay so
that you don't do anything there the
next character in s2 is a space M does
not equal a space so you don't do
anything
r does not the next character is an R
don't do anything the next characters
you don't do anything then an L don't do
anything then an e don't do anything
space and then suddenly we get to an M
so we're still in the outer for loop
we're still looking at em right and
we're comparing M with every other
letter inside the S - and suddenly we
reach here where we're comparing M with
an M and we say yes they are equal so
we're going to print out
something make that into better check
we're going to print common letter and
then we're going to break this break
says do not keep looking at the
remaining letters in s2 okay so once
we've found one that fits that that once
we found one that matches stop right
here
break and print out the thing and then
go on to looking at I which is the next
letter and s1 and you do the same thing
compare I with I we have a match perfect
right off the bat so you print out
another common letter and then you break
which means don't keep looking at the
remaining letters and then you look at
since you broke out of the inner loop
you go to the outer loop the next letter
is a T and so on and so on so
essentially you're comparing every
letter out here in s1 with every single
letter and s2 until you find one that
matches as soon as you do you exit so if
you if you actually run this program
it's going to print out seven times I
think we can check it okay one two three
four five six seven times
nice majority of the people all right if
you got this wrong please go back and
try to trace through your program so
that means step-by-step try to figure
out what values of variables are just to
make sure that you're on the right track
and you understand exactly what's
happening okay